- I'll give you anything.
How about my arch-dick Ferdinand.
(tires screeching)
(glass smashing)
(gunshots)
(pained yell)
Oh no!
This marks the beginning of World War Cum.
(dramatic music)
(gunshots)
(yelling in foreign language)
(explosions)
- Today, we are more than
a collection of penises.
We are a circle of jerks!
- I can't feel my balls,
I can't feel my balls!
- Hey, don't look down, look at me.
- Okay.
- Tell me about your farm in Virginia.
- The farm?
- Yeah, that's right.
- There's pigs as far as the eye can see.
- No!
No!
(somber music)
(plate smashing)
(sobbing)
- (singing) Cookies are the
talk of the neighborhood.
But come on honey, won't you
give me a slice of your pie.
I wanna nibble your
biscuits and your--
(glass smashing)
- Why are ya'll celebrating?
Good penises died, and for what?
(somber music)
- [Narrator] I felt like a lonely soldier
who watched his best
friend die in his arms,
and then came back a shell of a penis.
- Hello I'm Alan.
- [Andrew] Sorry a shell of a penis?
- Have you not been seeing the dicks?
- Huh?
- It's all I've been watching, honestly.
- Interesting.
- It's heartbreaking.